in Wiesbaden steht dieses Hochhaus bis
vor etwa einem Jahr war hier das
Finanzamt untergebracht doch dann zog
die Behörde aus jetzt steht das
14-stöckige Gebäude fast komplett leer
trotzdem muss das Land dafür weiter
Miete zahlen stolze 3,4 Millionen Euro
ja für ja
es ist ein unliegen also es ist
unglaublich zu begreifen also für jeden
Privatmensch wäre das also könnte keiner
solche Kosten irgendwie auf sich nehmen
und dass der Staat diese Gelder so
sinnlos raushaut mich macht das sauer
insgesamt diese Situation finde ich
beschissen es ist wirklich einfach
schade man das 3,4 Millionen damit kann
man viel mehr anfangen und gerade in
Wiesbaden könnte man es an anderer
Stelle auch brauchen das Wiesbadener
Bürogebäude gehört zu 55 Immobilien die
das Land Hessen vor rund 20 Jahren
verkauft hat um zu Geld zu kommen danach
wurden die Gebäude direkt wieder auf
Jahrzehnte angemietet mehr als die
Hälfte der 55 Mietverträge läuft bis zum
Jahr 2036 doch der scheinbar clevere
Deal wird zur Belastung für die
Steuerzahler wie im Fall des ehemaligen
Finanzamtes trotz des langfristigen
Mietvertrages zieht die Behörde anfangen
Oktober 2022 aus dem alten Gebäude in
diesen Neubau damit sind alle
Finanzämter unter einem Dach aber jetzt
zahlt das Land zweimal Miete für den
neuen Sitz für den uns niemand verraten
will wie viel und für das überflüssige
alte Hochhaus 3,4 Millionen Euro ich
persönlich finde es nicht professionell
gerade weil so langfristige Mietverträge
sich eigentlich auch aktuell erledigt
haben und oft nicht mehr so praktiziert
werden und einfach nicht wirtschaftlich
rentabel sind das Millionen Miete
bezahlt wird für leerstehendes Gebäude
ist völlig ungerecht an jedem
Steuerzahler
beim zuständigen Landesbetrieb Bau und
Immobilien Hessen verteidigt man die
doppelmiete schriftlich heißt es die
Mietzahlungen sind im marktüblichen
Bereich Herausforderungen im
Gebäudebetrieb können niemals
ausgeschlossen werden
Herausforderungen die die Steuerzahler
ein Haufen Geld kosten
hoffentlich findet sich das schnell eine
Lösung weil wenn das jetzt natürlich
noch paar Jahre so weitergeht hat keiner
irgendwie was davon wie es mit dem
Gebäude weitergehen soll ist völlig
unklar in Wiesbaden ist die Sorge groß
dass das ehemalige Finanzamt noch Jahre
ein Millionen Grab bleibt